je veux dire c'est que le fait même que
cet ancien ministre ancien conseiller
très proche de françois hollande songe à
se présenter
signe les chèques bien sûr du président
de république
ça c'est une évidence et je crois que il
veut faire coup double il veut d'abord
sur sa gauche empêché le président
république comme d'autres de se
représenter
et ils voudraient aussi sur sa droite ou
le centre capter l'électorat de françois
bayrou de françois pépin juppé ni droite
ni gauche donc je pense qu'il fait
effectivement ce calcul de la captation
à la fois d'un héritage sur sa gauche et
en même temps d'un positionnement de
françois bayrou qui a toujours affirmé
que son positionnement c'était le ni
brad ni qu'est-ce qu'ils capturent
quelque part le troisième débat de la
primaire ce qui va l'annoncer la veille
je crois pas non c'est de la politique
politicienne d'accord mais un coup de
billard à trois bandes
alors pour moi justement ça c'est trop
intelligent pour moi minutes sur
françois bayrou parce que je ne sais pas
ce que ça donnera un état sérieux
c'est pas que je vais dire les français
fauvin ce que je souhaite c'est qu'un
jour il puisse être élu essuyé sur son
nom mais quand on fait du terrain c'est
parce que nous demande des gens les gens
sont en train de nous dire on va faire
un un truc qu'on finit d'ailleurs par
perdre de vue sur lesquels on finit par
son bobine est soi même
non ça c'est la politique politicienne
je pense qu'il ya des attentes et des
douleurs des souffrances des français et
il faut dire exactement quel est le
projet candidat sérieux ou pas candidat
sérieux c'est un homme sérieux emmanuel
macron je suis quelqu'un que je respecte
mais je doute très franchement de sa
capacité il est en opposition totale
avec l'adn de la gauche française et par
conséquent il n'a pas non plus à droite
les électeurs de droite préféreront
toujours un projet clair vous avez déjà
vu françois fillon